this tea is really good
i hope that i won't be spilling any
today
same brain mugs link in the description
do you guys know what's in front of me
right now
of course you do airpods max they are
here
and i can't believe it these have been
rumored for quite a while but of course
they were rumored under the name of
airpods studio and when this name was
finally announced not only did people
have a lot to say about the name but
they had even more to say
about the price at 549
they're a pretty expensive pair of
headphones but are they worth it oh
should we get
this unboxing underway i thought we
would maybe go for
something a little tiny today just
kidding i don't even need a knife
do i
i'm so excited about this these come in
five different colors this is the space
gray there's also a silver a pink a sky
blue
and a green basically the same exact
colors as the new ipad air here we go
here we go here we go
oh wow
wow okay okay who says that who says
okay little john yes oh oh oh this is
paper i thought this was the color of
them
oh this is nice i'm looking off camera
at tyler he's like
pretty yeah okay here they are
gonna set them right there let's just
see what's in here um i was hoping
that they would have a matching
lightning cable for each of the
headphones but they don't it's just the
basic lightning to usbc i do wish that
they would have made these usbc but it
kind of makes sense because all of the
other airpods
in the airpods family are all lightning
and the phone is lightning
makes sense oh
it's magnetic
it's kind of like the smartfolio case on
the
ipad this soft mesh this kind of feels
like
the home pod covering super soft
this is the first taking out of the case
moment
there will never be another one after
this
oh they're light uh maybe do it for the
top down
go there will never be another
[Music]
at one
ear cups off speechless
okay let's get these connected we
basically are just able to
bring it next to each other and they
should automatically connect here we go
press the noise control button to switch
between noise cancellation and
transparency
the media control press the digital
crown wants to play pause twice oh my
goodness
i'm so ready they're connected they're
connected here we go here we go here we
go are you ready holy crap i'm excited
[Music]
oh it's such a nice
fit like you don't even feel this
sitting on your head
this is why they call it air pods
because it feels like i'm floating on a
freaking
cloud i need to listen to something
right now transparency mode is on tyler
say something
hi hey i can hear you hello
i wish the oh and it's like so super
clear it's almost like i'm not even
wearing these
i don't even feel this touching the top
of my head it's so
wild okay noise cancellation is now on
i heard you say something i don't know
what you said play noah cyrus july
so if you press the digital crown button
that activates siri i'm going to turn up
with the digital crown oh and even it
has a little click sound
that the apple watch makes
i have it so loud like i think it's all
the way up
i can't even i actually can't hear my
own voice right now you gotta put these
on
get over here get over here so you're
probably gonna have to adjust this a
little bit i actually never even
adjusted it yet
i was even listening to that over top of
my hair whoa
whoa whoa whoa i'm waiting what do you
think i can't hear myself
right i can't hear myself i know am i
still talking
yeah i just keep saying well i know
laugh now cry later by drake
the tears of twitter taste delicious i
have them turned up all the way
and i'm yelling and i can't hear my
voice
and it is perfectly it's perfectly clear
with no distortion at all this is the
loudest that i've ever heard tyler ray's
voice i've heard literally i have no
idea what you're doing
i have never heard him talk louder this
is it
okay okay wait aren't they comfy oh my
god i'm
so in shock right now because like i
knew they were gonna be good
and i know everyone's expecting me to be
like apple fan girl justine you got an
eye in front of your name like you're
gonna like them no matter what
no i am honestly
genuinely surprised
oh my gosh i can't believe that i can't
hear myself this is so weird
you know hold on you know what this fine
gentleman drake once said
what we started from the bottom now we
here
[Music]
i mean i don't know what else to say
like i'm honest this is i am not being a
fan
girl right now because i really wanted
to be critical
i wanted to have something to say
they're incredibly comfortable
like i don't feel this on the top of my
head a lot of headphones
you'll be able to feel this pressure on
the top of your head
where i do feel most of the pressure is
kind of interesting because it is sort
of like right around here
but it's giving you that seal around
your ear
i still have transparency mode on and it
sounds like i'm talking perfectly clear
but
there's nine microphones on here did you
know that we're gonna get into the tech
details
i want to do that before i did the test
but now i'm so shook i can't even think
straight when they first announced this
obviously the airpods are meant to be
wireless but
for me as an editor and for a lot of
other people who do a lot of stuff where
you need to have no latency
in editing or in some type of music
production i need to be able to plug
these in so this
is their lightning to 3.5 millimeter
audio jack
this is crazy because i still have the
transparency mode on so i can kind of
hear
my hair rubbing on the microphone but it
sounds so perfectly clear
that it's like i'm talking without these
on and then when i lift this up
it automatically disconnects from my
phone and then as soon as i put it back
on
i hear it again connecting to my phone i
got distracted
so this is the lightning to 3.5
millimeter and i'm looking for something
similar to this style for
our podcast that my sister and i do if
you guys may have seen that we have mugs
now
tea has never tasted better i wanted to
use these for podcasting but you have to
plug them in so that's where this
comes into play so this is a lightning
to 3.5
millimeter headphone jack so i'll be
able to use this and plug this into our
road caster
so we can use these as we normally would
use other headphones for
our podcasting and i am gonna try this
out because we're actually shooting our
podcast tomorrow so this saturday
if you guys want to check out our
podcast where i'm going to be using
these
check out youtube.com same samebrain or
you can find us on apple podcasts at
same brain
or you can go to anchor.fm slash same
brain i love wherever you listen to a
podcast it's probably there
that's going to be a real test because
we'll be wearing these for like over an
hour and a half
the comfort level oh anyway there's so
much more that i need to tell you about
these
so the new airpods maps have a high
fidelity audio with an apple designed a
40 millimeter dynamic driver that will
produce well-balanced sound
across the entire audible range these
also have a pair of apple h1 chips for
computational audio
that is capable of executing over 9
billion operations per second
to adapt the audio to the fit and seal
of your ear this is called
adaptive eq this actually measures the
sound signal being delivered to your
ears and will be able to adjust the low
and mid frequencies in real time
based on the fit and the seal around
your ear
also taking into account glasses hair
or even piercings so for the noise
cancellation they have eight microphones
that's able to capture and cancel
all of the unwanted noise there's three
outward facing microphones on each ear
cup and there's one
on the inside that's able to listen to
the sound of what your ears are hearing
so using that h1 chip it's able to
analyze the data
and is able to create an equal and
opposite sound that will then reduce the
unwanted sound
transparency mode is something that is
on almost all higher end headphones at
this point
so this will allow you to turn off the
noise cancellation so you'll be able to
hear the world around you you're able to
turn this on
or off on your iphone your apple watch
or even on the headphones directly
with this button right here spatial
audio is also something that is very
interesting and they did announce this
before
and it is in the latest airpods pro with
the latest ios update but i actually
have not tried this yet so this is going
to be so exciting that i'm going to be
able to test out the spatial audio for
the first time on the airpods pro max
so what this spatial audio is is it
basically gives you a theater-like
experience
with dynamic head tracking so the sound
is always mapped
directly to your content so as you move
your head the accelerometer and the
gyroscopes both
in your airpods your iphone or your ipad
will constantly be tracking and
comparing the motion of your head
to your device so apple is obviously
known for their attention to detail and
design and i really
love the look of these so this is a
stainless steel
headband and it has a mesh headrest and
these memory foam
ear cushions which magnetically attach
to your air pods and you can also mix
and match these
if you want to get an extra pair so
they're 65 apiece so you can get them as
a replacement or if you just want a
different color the digital crown
is a really nice feature that is pulled
from the apple watch and this will let
you adjust the volume by turning the
dial or
push once to play pause or answer a call
twice to skip forward
three times to skip back and then press
hold for siri there's an optical sensor
in each cup that will detect when it's
placed on your head
and positional sensors where the
headband meets each ear cup that will be
able to detect the movement and rotation
there's also an additional ninth
microphone that is used to enhance your
voice during phone calls
these have a 20 hour battery life and
this smart case for storage
there's a built-in magnet that activates
the case detect
and the sensor in each ear cup so that
it'll be able to place the airpods max
into an ultra low power state to
preserve the battery
so we're now going to do a spatial audio
test i've never tried this before
i know it is in the air pods pro but for
whatever reason i
haven't tried it yet so today is the day
we've got the mandalorian
all loaded up here so the control center
when you long press into the volume
this gives you your noise transparency
control and then you can also turn
spatial audio
off or on let me turn it off and see
what that sounds like first
spatial audio is off turning my head
nothing's happening now let's
turn it on okay now it's on
[Music]
oh my gosh
it's like i'm in the mandalorian right
now
hold that thought hold that thought
try spatial audio once
becomes a jedi very quickly
the look on tyler's face is very scared
let's see here
will i hurt myself or somebody
yep where does that leave us in terms of
this review
[Music]
spatial audios cool dude
oh another test podcast
test there it is ready for podcasting
look at that it's so small hello
hello hello turn this up oh my gosh it's
freaking perfect it sounds like i have
transparency mode on but i don't because
i'm talking through the microphone and
it's coming through my head
what if you put transparency then it's
just gonna really mess with me hello oh
this is just weird i'm talking to myself
through myself
oh my goodness jenna is gonna lose her
mind tomorrow we're gonna get jenna's
reaction
and she's incredibly cynical it's hard
to impress her i think she's gonna be
impressed
try with glasses with glasses i gotta
try with glasses you have glasses on
yeah it feels good podcast game
has just been elevated
oh man my head is small
this is perfect i don't even know it's
been really difficult i'm sure many
people who wear glasses
have had the struggle of wearing glasses
with headphones tyler's like yup me
i mean i i also wear glasses but most of
the time i do wear contacts
but this is nice this is nice
well thank you guys so much for watching
this was kind of just a first look at a
first impression of the airpods pro max
i kept keep calling it the pro max but
it's just the max
i am honestly way more impressed than i
thought i was going to be because
obviously like i knew they were going to
be cool because they are incredibly
expensive but here's the thing
you're paying for what you're getting
it's crazy
i know i know i know like i know
it's totally beyond anything i
expected like the same thing be nice
[Music]
but
[Applause]
so
you